i mean we've been kicking in here though
since i got here you're like one of the
first people we started kicking with
when we first got here
i was like talking [ __ ] at the creek
yeah we yeah and you're like yeah i hate
black people too
we just went off with it and we just
kept going after a while and you're like
all right
and we recorded the podcast we did those
uh man on the street videos yeah we did
all sorts of stuff like right when i
first met you yeah i don't know what i
was saying but i was saying some stupid
stuff
but i wasn't like trying to be offensive
or anything i think i was like talking
about asians and black people or
something yeah we started making jokes
we went back and forth for a while we
were disagreeing with each other i'm
like yeah this is yeah is there like an
order to this did you just put them
wherever uh it's like this right here do
you have to do these ones too or not
um
yeah
oh i yeah those are the ones that were
on top i don't know if you have like a
um i'm just gonna do it like the form
the standard
the default yeah you're not even in the
camera
yes i don't think she wants to be no no
i'm saying well now she's doing this oh
you're really not at all i can't see you
yeah you don't exist to us
all right not like all of these not all
of these go in there right yeah all of
these do no okay i was about to say
there's way more of these than those of
those because it's for six players but
we only have four player three players
there's the
but yeah i mean i thought that was so
weird when
that guy came and i wasn't expecting it
and then
i wish that we had four because four is
better
like four is a good number to play with
yeah
but i i i think three is like faster so
if you have to get to the airport
that'll be better
401
well we're down to 2 hours and 45
minutes it'd be like that do you have
any more packing to do
no so you're just pretty much just gonna
go to the house you grab your bag and
you gotta do it i'm gonna put it in
there okay
but it's all in one place well that
means we gotta leave beforehand because
we gotta get all the way back together
oh [ __ ] right and then you gotta like
put the stuff and then we gotta go to
the area if we're at your house by 6 30
if we're that means we've got to leave
so where do we have essentially two
hours yeah
two hours
we can teach a rookie to play in two
hours yeah
i'm a professional teacher we got this
nice
you don't have to do it through zoom
you can do it face to face exactly
exactly
so you place
a settlement
and a road
what's the difference between a
settlement in the road a settlement is a
settlement
and then the settlement is like that's
what a settlement looks like yeah okay
and then you get all three of these
so how do you choose where you set it
you choose two spots in the beginning to
start out with so you just choose
randomly
yeah but you want to choose one with a
lot of dots on it
a lot of dots okay so what's gonna
happen is
what do you mean dots the way you get
resources is by rolling your dice
okay
if the dice any of us
rolls on a number that you have
you get to pick up [ __ ] from that
spot
so
do you have the cards honey yeah
that would make the most sense
all right um
yes
so
and then you buy things and you see the
cost try to get 10 points
so how do you win you get 10 points
and if you have four of any resource you
can trade them in for one of any other
resource
i never tell people and they're like so
how do you know where to set stuff like
that you're setting up here is it
right here oh okay it tells you how to
set up everything okay that's i would do
random but i don't know because this is
for six players
so i don't know what the correct
numerology is
good times
so uh how how lit was the party at the
creek today
it was chill it wasn't like crazy but
there's a lot of people there
that like for just like a night of just
hanging out it's kind of cool though i
do what i do like about the creek is
that comics just hang out there yeah
like it's like a i wish
and i don't know if it had anything to
do with marty clark when he was there he
ran it but i feel like the creek used to
be more comic friendly and it doesn't
feel as comic friendly as it used to
but tonight it did and that was cool
yeah
but like i wish there was a comedy club
that was very comic friendly where
comics can just like go and hang out and
like feel like welcome to be there all
the time yeah creek was kind of that
spot but i feel like it felt less so
once marty was out
okay i don't know close with marty by
the way i had an experience in houston
i was hanging out with some comic
friends
and
it was more like a
comic
dressing room common
room
like it wasn't the green room it was
closed off to everybody else so comics
had a space to be around comics but not
around everyone else before they went up
on stage
and after yeah yeah
oh green room yeah every any good comedy
venue or stage it's just okay okay yeah
that's
that's what i was wondering about to
hear it described that way i was like i
never thought about it like that but
that's exactly what it is yeah that
comics can oh i didn't know you didn't
either like comics can just go to get
away from like regular people and just
like because it's kind of there is like
a comics well because there's like a
disconnect that you want before you
perform like it's like weird you don't
want to be like talking to the audience
yeah get called up like you want to like
separate yourself as a performer versus
the audience because like we're not i'm
not like just like a regular one of you
going up yeah you can't be in that
mindset of just hanging out i need to be
like ready to perform and it's like a
different mindset
and you can't just like be talking or
exactly trying to hang out
for sure i feel that completely
um
it's like a locker room
yeah
did you have their locker room talk like
is there like comic talk
yeah comics are the worst
like comics are like i we were today we
were playing ball
and there were these two little kids
they're probably like
maybe eight years old wait why are you
hanging out with eight-year-olds what's
happening they're around it's a park
it's a park okay we're playing ball at a
party all right he wasn't no yeah i'm
not fighting here it's fine that's
comics so keep them so what's comics
were playing ball at a park and these
like eight-year-olds wonder like we go
how many points do you guys think we got
next and we're just like
[ __ ] we don't want to play with these
kids but it's you know we don't want to
be an adult yep it's a party and so
there were some other guys playing on
the other side and the kids were like
like playing kind of juggling around on
our court i was like hey
uh these kids said that we're garbage
they don't want to play with us they
said they're going to trash us but they
say that you guys look good you guys
should play with that
and so the other guys were like fine and
they like played the game with the kids
but i'm like honestly your parents are
thanking us you don't want your kids
hanging around comics like even just the
actual conversation we're having as the
game goes on yeah we're like we're going
to traumatize these children
the
best thing for these kids is that they
did not play with us okay so you really
think that anything that you guys would
have to say is worse than what these
kids are seeing right now on the
internet unbridled untamed who do you
think comes up with the stuff that
people say
like a lot of them
i guess if it's personal it's like it's
it hits harder yeah but like a lot of
memes that i see online they're just i
don't know what came first the comedy
bits are the memes but i feel like a lot
of memes someone heard a funny comedy
joke they liked and they made a movie
rolling for a turn sure it's just
highest number do you ever feel like
that yeah like a lot of memes someone
just heard a comedy bit they like and
made a meme out of it yeah that's like
what a lot of memes are and that's the
[ __ ] up part yeah five i don't even
want to go first dude you don't want i
mean it's
it doesn't really matter
ten
so you go so you go first and then it
goes to the left to the left all right
what do i do myself to begin with so
it's you give yourself a settlement and
a road
a settlement yeah
and a road
i've played before i know what's up
but yeah i mean it's a different energy
when there's like a lot of comedians in
one space and they're just talking [ __ ]
to each other
exactly i'm telling you it's just it's
different
i mean
i will say like with teachers like
there's a reason that you you put a
door on the teacher's room
you know you need a space away from the
children i i wouldn't say i spent a lot
of time in there but somebody needs this
piece see also that's the same thing
comedians need buffers from regular
people because comedians have found
we don't like not even like in a weird
way like i've just i've noticed that our
like levels of what our jokes are are
just different yeah always hang out with
like comics and i'll say something and
like comics won't even like bat an eye
but like regular people be like oh
you just like like someone if you do
that with comedians then you're a loser
but also
not to do that straight straight up too
like the nature of my job is such that
like i did you want more love
i
would love a glass of water as well if
you don't mind
um it's just yeah the nature of what i
do is like it's my job to react to
things
so it like i spend all summer kind of
getting out of that mindset and letting
myself be comfortable with kind of like
a different way of speaking and thinking
about things and then it's like
you gotta go right back to being on top
of that so
yeah i
i've literally i
my sense of humor is very
you good on this yeah out there but i've
kind of had to train myself because
it's even how you react to things like
in a classroom like you can't just crack
up you can't just react to something
you already you you already showed up
your whole hand by doing that so you got
to kind of
poke her face like that's that's not
funny we don't we don't do that here
yeah and like to like in my mind in my
mind i'm like you said something funny
but that was straight up genius like
bless your heart from the mouth of babes
that's the funny part is like for
example betty white died right oh and
then like my god literally three
different comics found out at three
different times and you know what the
first response was every single one of
them
betty white that
finally like right off the bat three
comics in a row we're like oh finally
like how could that possibly be your
reaction that's exactly my point like
comics think different you are you like
you were blessed with her greatness but
see that's the thing but thinking like
comics and thinking comedy wise every
comic is thinking about the joke that's
what i'm talking about sure it's just a
different mentality yeah it's just an
example of okay but if you're thinking
about the joke then how are you not
thinking about being unique too and like
an individual here but yeah you are
you're trying to yeah i guess no also
let's be honest like i'm trying to like
all the easiest how many times happiest
jokes
yeah like
maybe how many comics like you made a
name relationship with how we skirt over
the hackiest part and then go to
something more unique like some people
are better at it than others but also
like timing wise when something's like
immediate reaction it usually is the
lowest common denominator you know
because like it's just what's like
because it's not thought out it's just
like the first thing that comes to your
mind well you're trying to be funny
you're not trying to be uh reverent or
give a eulogy you're trying to direct a
crowd of apes and make them laugh and be
like in an institute yeah tacos penises
like that like i don't try to do my
comedy like dirty or to like make the
comics in the back of the room laugh
like that
yeah i've always thought like that's i
don't know i've never done comedy for
the back of the room like i want to make
people that paid money to see me as a
comic like have a good time but also
yeah comedy for me so it's like this
catch 22 of what i find funny which
thing yeah because you're a comic
i just i don't but i also don't find it
funny i feel like it's like cheap you
know like when i first said well when i
first started doing comedy i was doing
comedy around like a lot of older comics
and a lot of old school guys you know
and they would always be like and a lot
of the comics are around were like oh
you know like the word like [ __ ] and
talking dirty like that's not the joke
you can make it a part of your joke but
don't make that the punch line that you
just said something dirty like a shock
value kind of statement you know like
say something with what you're saying
and somebody stopped hanging around too
many comics and you become more shock
value yeah not even if you're hanging
around too many comics but like if
they're comics that you're hanging
around that's what they value like right
you know you don't want to perform for
like comics only too much yeah like you
don't want to just be like open miking
like you don't want like that you can
tell like when someone just does only
open mics because they're like then
they'll go in front of an audience and
the audience will be like oh like we
don't like this at all but like they're
just so used to getting launched they're
playing like
football with like people who push back
or like
yeah and then they're also sort of like
disgruntled they're like uh whatever you
guys don't like that who cares hey yeah
it's you it's your fault what's wrong
with you yeah look at this guy
it's it's good because honestly i'd like
to see you um
apply that mindset to catan because now
like
i know
like that's kind of the point here right
it's like you're you're a comics comic
but you're trying to be like the
the stevie wonder right like you're
trying to write
trying to be stuffed
for the comic to enjoy but also because
everybody gets down to that like you
know it's like something for everyone
but well you shouldn't be writing for
the comics you shouldn't be writing for
the audience the audience you should
should be ready for you always yep
that's the thing
okay perfect see so you're you're
actually really prepared for this then
well so you're gonna place the
settlement down and the road oh i right
because i have to
yeah yeah so look at all these vertexes
i know okay this one has five dots one
plus four dots plus two dots so i'm
trying to find 11. so you're trying to
find like the ideal place for yeah can
you put them out so the point though too
is as a gambling man five three if it's
red
if you can see a lot of dots underneath
it
that means the dice is
statistically more likely to land there
so
you want your [ __ ] there because
you will get stuff off of it if your
dice lands on it and rocks so first of
all then sheep sheep is the least
valuable and rock is the most valuable
in terms of what in terms of resources
yeah it's just more valuable or like
okay
all right i mean i'm thinking
but yeah i mean i think it's
good to be different and like be always
thinking of a joke but i'd never tried
to be more of a comedian i just try to
be like a person that does comedy right
because you don't want to get lost in
the sauce
bro you can't get lost in the sauce
that's facts i love that you ever seen
the gucci mane skit where he's like he's
like is there such a thing as too much
sauce he's like no you can't add too
much sauce but you can't get lost in the
sauce
that's definitely a thing
i think when you get lost in the sauces
when you're trying to do something or be
somebody
versus just being who you are instead of
trying to do it you're like i need to be
a comedian yeah i need to prove this to
you
and yes and uh
you know that reminds me of what your
mother said yeah hey
but just like being in that mode i think
it's like so when you put the road there
is it connected to all three of those or
just those two this is gonna be an
important thing so after this round
you're it's gonna cost you to put these
things down so what you just put down is
what you get to put down for free this
one round is going to be a settlement
and a road okay so
ultimately
you're trying to add up to 10 points
in value
right that's going to
ultimately win you points but
to be able to build settlements
they're going to have to be
two away from each other so this is one
space
it's just a direction you want to head
towards this is two okay so i'm going to
need at least two roads to make it
another settlement
that's an investment okay
you can
you also don't want to get cut off
especially build a road here and someone
has to be a container
you might get [ __ ] so you want to make
sure that uh you don't get [ __ ] by uh
building towards really popular areas
okay but essentially
you can benefit from
having longer roads settlements what is
this worth two points no on his own one
one point yeah a city so now it's your
turn two points so it's it's my turn
yeah
so all right so this is what i'm
thinking just based off of what i've
seen you guys do and
where i would go it's gonna be here
that's a beautiful spot to go and i'd
put the road here i love that for you
that was a really good spot i probably
should have gone there and now you go
again
okay so i go again yeah yeah because you
went last okay so what do i do when it's
my turn the same thing that you just did
so i got to set another row yep this is
that special round where you get to do
this okay for free um okay i didn't know
you went last so you get to go
okay so i didn't i didn't know that i
was gonna do this would give me like
half a second so what do you think about
uh
comedians
and hanging out with them from what
you've seen from us so far that's
interesting i have a lot of friends who
are comedians how did that happen well
that's how we met like oh yeah because i
met her i don't side note um i'm sorry i
don't mean to interrupt this is rude did
you tell your moment i just was like
giving an interest like just how we met
yeah i've known her since boston by the
way
so yeah she's visiting out of town from
boston so yeah that's where i started
doing comedy and we met because
one of the comics i used to do comedy
with
was her his girlfriend now wife was your
college roommate and then uh so you came
to a show and
unfortunately yes yeah
yeah so you were asking me how i feel
about spending time with comics and i
was saying
before ben stole my spotlight
yeah then that was really rude it was
ben's the worst
um yeah
so
a lot of my friends are comics yeah yeah
they're great they're yeah they're just
like anyone else yeah they're like
anyone else yeah
um i mean anyone could be good at what
they do in battle it is funny to me
though the funniest thing to me about
comics
is you guys have you guys are like that
l word you guys have very specific rules
about
who can date who when people can date
and how they can date in like what
capacity yeah it's very serious
community we are all [ __ ] each other
and oh if we [ __ ] then we get closer so
okay
i love it though i love that community i
think i think it's great i'm all about
people having their communities so yeah
yeah i think it's great because we're
adults and there's no like restrictions
against sex so it's like it naturally
forms i also just think would it be so
what so could i do this by the way yeah
okay you can't do that would you survive
but i don't
because we're setting our next
settlements right yeah you just want to
maximize dots right now dude and if you
feel like you're maximizing your dots
and you're putting yourself in a good
position to build a contiguous road you
don't have any right you want your roads
to be touching
you want your roads to be touching yeah
so you don't want to build too far from
yourself like that's not a bad if you
build right there then you don't have
any wood
oh you you do want to maximize which is
fine you wanna hedge your beds here you
wanna so which one's wood
anything that gives you a forest
okay i see so this gives me this and
what does this give me just grab sheet
sheet so this is sheep and this is wheat
okay so that's what i'm saying because
the other spot that i was looking at
that i think would be dope you did get
would be down here because that's also
maximizing yeah i didn't know but now
you're putting yourself into competition
with this bad boy over here that's what
that's what i'm saying i think i didn't
know if it's better to build closer to
like you're you're asking about some
great quantities in life but i think
like comedians are
fun to hang out with
but like i think that's not fun to play
play with actually really uh really the
perfect mix because
their art form requires uh humility
uh and also to be adept in social
situations if i build here can i use
wood from there to here yeah
it doesn't matter where you get it you
can build anywhere
it's about getting resources so that you
will then spend to do other things so
yeah yeah it sounds like
this is a good spot
uh when i get more dots on this spot
oh yeah because that would be totally
six times yeah you're correct i love
that totally wrong i love
get it get it right yeah you're doing
really great right now
uh yeah i know nothing but i'm jon snow
in it i know nothing [ __ ]
whatever dude we
tempered um but yeah i mean i think it's
good to be around a bunch of different
people but
i like comics man but they're a lot
yeah
but also the one other thing that i just
that i find really interesting is like a
lot of comics
they end up sounding just like the
comics they're always hanging out with
you know what i'm saying like it'll be
like a crew of comics yeah like a click
of comics and you could tell them
because all of their materials or
premises are the same
and like
all their punch lines go to the same
places
you know like all the punchlines always
going to end in like oh you're gay
you're like uh
you know like there's like some
there's like uh
like yeah like people inform each other
and some people like have styles where
they they bounce off each other more
and like assume each other's identities
more
but it's also like go there yeah oh but
it's also yeah go there
a lot of uh
a lot of uh you know uh
a lot of comics are independent and i
don't know if they always uh
like being in groups because i feel like
the nature of comedy is very independent
that's i've always wondered that because
i'm a fiercely independent person like
it's
it's hard for me to like be a part of
like any group or anything like that
because i always feel so i've always
wondered if that's like a part of doing
comedy is like the independence of doing
comedy that feeling that you say
whatever the [ __ ] you want and like it's
weird if you don't have that because
then why don't you just do improv
like
it's weird because you have to want to
be alone on stage and talk and like have
everyone listen to you but also you want
to like
be a part of a scene and be with people
and stuff so it's a weird dichotomy of
the person who does comedy i think it's
the perfect mix because like in football
you're like left guard or
you know that's probably an important
position but you're like just one small
part of it but when you're doing comedy
you're all of it like you get to control
every aspect you don't have to just like
do your little part that's the beauty of
it i think that's why you love it like
that it's just you there's a celebration
of the individual yeah because
everything is like it doesn't matter if
you're talking about like a relationship
or your girlfriend or whoever it's like
anyone can talk about their girlfriend
but your experience with your girlfriend
is what creates the com comedic
perspective you know like in the sense
that like everyone has a lot of people
have a girlfriend but no one has no one
is you with your girlfriend like your
specific experience your voice your
everything it's too close to the red oh
you're [ __ ] yeah i mean uh i'm not
spending this long
it's totally cool
oh yeah
yeah am i crazy isn't it
their perspective this is a standard
board okay it was on the sticker
it's tricky
because you know dots or whatever dots
or whatever
it's all about them dots
oh that's all about them dippin dots
um
yeah i mean uh
i feel like uh of all the things you
could do
like in terms of jobs it's like
i think comedy is a good avenue it's
just not
economically very viable but if you're
supposed if you're just pursuing
something for the fun of it i think
stand up comedy is a perfect er as a
beautiful mix of being social and being
like artistic
i've always said like with comedy like
if i stop having fun with it i'll be
done with it like in the sense that i
just do it for the fun you know like
yeah if i'm gonna choose to do something
i'm gonna i'm not gonna choose to do
something i don't like yeah oh
and i don't like it
i don't like it either
so i just wanna know
why can she go here let me wait this is
what i think it is that she couldn't go
here because it's one dot away versus
that's two yeah so like this one's one
two so she can go there but she can go
there yeah is that right yeah okay cool
that makes
sense i do that
no
okay do you have to set your settlement
you already have that okay so i just
have that by placing my house yeah
okay
which i was kind of mad about because i
was going to build there what's like
what do you do right now like what is
even good oh and you get the second
settlement that you put down so you get
wood brick and sheep so just pick up
wood brick and sheep should i have done
it for my first settlement too no just
your second oh just your second one yeah
okay
all right so wood brick and sheep and
that's because this one's touching
wood
brick and sheet yeah okay cool
so i'm taking brick and rock
yeah but you don't get oh you don't get
to do that for your first one
yeah just the second one
all right
you want to roll it in the box
that one
i rolled it in yours two
snake eyes
what happens if you roll a two
well no one has your box so you you roll
again
is touching a two you get a thing okay
what do i do you roll again i roll again
yeah no one had a two
okay i rolled a
11. yeah
so anyone who has something touching
this get something and this
okay so just her in this case yeah and
then she gets to build something
oh she gets to build now i see
okay yeah thank you
yeah she can build a settlement or a
road now yeah
don't you think like stockbrokers
are like
like inherently evil like to talk to
socially i don't that's the thing
you just casually ask people just in
terms of like
averages like the most evil people per
job comedians i think you're really
gonna okay i don't think this is the
thing i used to think there was like
evil people and jobs i don't think
there's any evil people it's
incentivized
i think there's just people that are
just doing a job the same way that we do
some people can't do certain jobs some
people can't be meat packing workers
because they can't stand blood like if
you're okay making poor people like more
poor
i feel like that does something
but they're not waking up being like oh
today i'm gonna go make poor people more
poor like that's the perspective you see
outside of that but i'm saying that
affects their personality and it makes
them hard to talk to because it makes
them sort of like yeah but there's
someone sociopaths but there's probably
someone out there that's really like
that but there's someone from like oh
comedians they just want to be a
comedian so they can say [ __ ] up
hateful [ __ ] about a bunch of different
like genders and racism but you're doing
it to people like inherently like it's
it's the other people are approving or
disapproving of you so it's like you you
are you're tied into society so so you
say because the audience choose the
audience essentially reaction is your
approval or disapproval which makes it
right or not right based off their
reactions
is that right to you okay yeah i mean uh
when you're done you just pass it up so
you're saying like because like stock
brokers aren't being judged on a daily
basis there's no one being like that's a
good trade like or that's a bad rate
like incentives are to make more money
yeah well and i okay
so so i just think of
sort of incentives as like what makes
something more statistically likely to
occur yeah right
incentives it's it's all behaviors wait
there's another so what's more like this
stock broker so does she get two or no
no oh yeah she gets two she gets two and
you get one yeah okay i get
two one wood and one rock thanks yeah i
didn't see myself over there so she gets
so far away
or anyone want brick
yeah ben we forgot to tell you on your
turn you can trade for things if you
want to do that what do i like you just
put up and it's just like 2k
somebody gives you an offer you can give
them counter offer or you can accept i
like that you put it in terms you would
understand so i'm i'm very can okay so
why did you put that there because i
accidentally i thought it's the bank i'm
giving that back i thought i thought i
needed the card but i already had one so
i put it back also supposed to have one
what you are showing us right now
if i'm gonna lie why would i like to
give myself less i know that's why i
trust you and what you have out on the
table right now is is your hand okay
well i'm not supposed to have this on
the table like not really okay you're
giving us
cause you guys put them out there right
now
this is the bank okay my bad
i guess again so like
oh so you're awesome so he's showing you
what's in his hand right now he's kind
of putting his dick out on the table for
you to take a look at you have shape
he wants your sheep he wants my sheep so
does he want this is it do i need
like one of everything to build a
settlement is that what that means in
this thing
yeah
so like in order to build you need to
build a road first to build a settlement
but i need but okay so i need to build a
road which i need one wood cart and one
brick card to build a road yeah and then
once i build a road i could build a
settlement with one wood brick and sheep
okay or you could build a city
with two e and three rock okay you know
i'm not trading with you i'm done okay
yeah we got ours we got our [ __ ] you
guys got a [ __ ] okay
okay so so there's a dangle touching
that and then you'll touch an ad
dingleberry so i get one wheat card
because i have this yeah so what i'm
saying but i shouldn't tell you guys
that yeah well
we know and it's our job to keep track
of you don't need to write like we're
the prosecution you don't need to prove
the case for us like you got to make us
because so do you get six or no or is
that enough that's a nine okay yeah all
right that's why so you're when you're
touching a six like that that's really
nice because it's see how it's red like
and
all those dots and you have to buy
something now so now i have to buy
something yeah okay you can buy
something you may yeah you know what i
mean so i can build a ship but i can
build a road because you sure can and
that's a good thing to do because if
you're a seventh generation okay so i
can build a road anywhere
it has to be touching another road or a
house a host a house
okay so
if i put my road in this is just a
hypothetical here can i put my road here
and it'd be touching all of these dots
or no yeah
but here's the thing
in order for you to build a house
you have to have it two roads away build
a settlement so i'm kind of blocking oh
sorry actually i couldn't put a room it
doesn't help you much to go in my
direction
right here well that's what i was asking
so like i couldn't build a house there
you can't build a house there you have
two roads to build a house that's a good
spot too your house has to be two roads
away from your other house or any other
house okay so i have to ask what makes
this good is because i have access to
tutorials
so ideally the best spot to build
would be probably either connecting to
this road so i can build a house
somewhere around there or connecting
right here so i could do two to one
breaks
yeah another thing too that's good for
you to know
oh yeah
take your turn and then i'll explain
just explain one thing so
right now what you have is a settlement
okay you can convert a settlement into a
city
and you'll get double
windfall every time something lands on
your [ __ ] okay so but you need this to
convert it to a city right but okay
remember how we told you how much is
this one point yeah i said he's worth
two points
yeah
okay
so just yeah
it's hard because there's like
beginning game strategy middle game
strategy and game strategy yeah
but you got this
okay and you want to i'm honestly
more stressed out about losing okay so
that would just be a slap in the face we
should probably just you want to use it
could i put a can i put a road right
here
yeah but then it's going to take longer
to build a settlement because then
you're going to have to build another
road oh because two roads have to be
touching right yeah okay so i see what
you mean
okay
so for the time being
plus if you go here you can use your
conversion decision but you said that
this is more dots you think that's
better
i mean because less than you can start
blocking that's five times what i'm
saying this is nine right or no it'll
just be six here
yeah only six literally only six whereas
if you go here you have more options but
if you put it here does it but it
doesn't count for all of these if i go
here does it it doesn't count for
anything until you have a house anyway
would you need two roads for i see okay
so this would be eight nine
and this would be
seven so i probably want to go here
but
well let's go ahead so i think uh
stockbrokers if you choose to do that
then it makes you a worse person so you
should choose to do jobs okay so what
are jobs
that you would recommend a person
getting okay so who's turning whatever
they pass the dice okay so what are jobs
that are like
acceptably conscious for you
uh greenpeace
antifa
that's pretty funny what's your role
an eight
and eight right five plus three is eight
yeah
i mean i think that
so you grab a card your job is
your job yeah
hey
your job is like a largest part of you
and if you uh don't have any discipline
to what you choose to do then you're
like we should explain also about sevens
so what so you grabbed two cards right
so
did you grab the right number you have
two cards
i
have an eight here and an eight here so
i pick up okay so yeah so oh so you pick
up one thing i have here and then one
from wood there
yeah that's okay cool cool
right yeah i mean you don't have to no
no no i was trying to figure out what
she was doing i'm just trying to learn
the game yeah no i'm stealing things
don't question me what's the other way
i don't know if you know the sounds but
she's jewish she oh [ __ ] here it is here
it is the anti-semitism
well listen every company
if any if you follow any good conspiracy
theory and there are a lot out there
they all kind of end up there and it's
unfortunate it really is because there's
a lot to be suspicious about out there
but i'll be honest with you if it's
going to be about the jews like
i'm a public school teacher and i'm
really just still waiting for my check
like for my jew gold check like
when's it coming if i if i control all
of wall street well it's like because
all of you know
hollywood like
yeah
why am i not driving a lamborghini right
now right well that's right why are you
not i mean guys we should be partying
it's not like all of you are rich or
whatever but it's like the jobs that you
occupied were like
jobs that uh were occupied by an
outsider
and
oh we we can talk about forced
assimilation all day
vietnam the chinese minority do the
banking and they're looked upon the same
way as the jews are oh it's just like
then taught me some really fun history
about that the other day actually
it's like a just
game theory and like game theory where
you end up in the uh
society and your role in it
that's that's a whole nother thing well
okay yeah anyway i'm supposed to be
taking a turn right now but i'm i'm
getting
i'm getting educated so every one of
your turns you can build right if you're
if you have what it takes to build
something correct okay
so i would like to offer
i'd like to offer
some
a piece of wood for some hay i will give
you a piece of wood if you will give me
a piece of hay
we're just i'm good well wait you were
just talking about cooperating with
people you know
yeah you don't want to do things in a
way that would be like monopolizing
resources or hoarding them in any way
right because we you would
spread them for the greatest benefit
right now we're competing
i like i told you guys i'm waiting for
my check like i'm all about this you
guys ever heard about the workmen circle
no
it's just a bunch of [ __ ] sick
communist jews they're homeless i'm
pretty sure that's just the russian flag
right
that's what that is right the workmen
sickle
on the russian flag
no a circle oh circle i thought you said
sickle
i don't know that all right one for one
of them um but yeah i mean it's your
turn
okay no um so i think what did i do i
did a thing
i was offering for a trade so nobody's
so what do you think about jobs and
stuff
jobs
all right
um
i think there's jobs and someone has to
do
and i wonder if a lot of the people hate
their job just like regular other people
hate their job like some job that people
see is evil somebody that does it thinks
they're like [ __ ] i hate this job but
they do it because it's a job and it
pays the money that they need to offer
you in life yeah i will offer two wood
for one head
so that's a one-time offer folks one two
three four five going once
going twice okay
daddy this this game is cold-blooded
okay yeah so that's your just like
instead of building something you're
just like okay yep okay okay just pass
my place right on over but you could
have built something still if you wanted
or not sure could have okay
uh yeah i just choose to do whatever i
want though you know
no do you think so you roll the three oh
gosh we got another one
um it's just like why would you choose
not to think about your job so if you
roll a three i can pull whatever's
touching this three yeah
okay
and why would you just let it go to the
wayside why would you not consciously
choose good jobs or something
um
do you want rock
do i want rock
or wood
what are you you're trading rocker wood
for what sheep are wheat
i feel like i don't know if i should be
trading on my
my jugul to you
okay
no i'm good
i don't know my resources are steady
right now so i feel like
[ __ ]
why'd you roll can i roll again
why is your
[ __ ] eight
no you can't roll again i'm joking
but it's cool because at least if i roll
an eight you guys are just getting more
of what you guys already have
so i can i can do whatever right
yeah
okay so if i wanted to i could build
what happens if i build
right here
uh settlement
yeah yeah you should do that
okay
so what do you think about
the so i just put a house right here
where would i put the house yeah
so what are you so then i need so to
build a settlement i need one word
one brick what do you think about the
comedy scene in austin wheat and one
sheet
okay
so yeah that's what i did all right cool
what do you what are your thoughts on
the comedy scene in austin
uh
so oh i rolled an eight by the way so if
you have stuff on it you can pick up
your
the comedy scene in austin is uh
it is a very
how do i
it's like the wild west is the best way
to describe it yeah it's yeah
it's like the wild west out here but i
like that it's like a hustler's
component to it i don't mind it
so yeah i mean we're all making it fresh
as we go so it's kind of new and
refreshing y'all are so rude so so you'd
grab a sod grab this uh
okay and then you'd grab a
sheep here
i see i would like to offer
one rock
for one
wheat
i don't have any weight
i just split my feet already
i put this a bit of settlement
what about um
a shep does anybody have a sheep
oh i would trade one rock for one sheep
no
i would take very nice care of your
sheep i have no sheep
does anybody have any sheep that i might
be able to no
i have no shame yeah cool all right cool
yeah
it was a fun turn
go ahead so what's the development card
thing that
that lets you do kind of meta game stuff
which is cool like because it kind of oh
a rock in the sheet to do it yeah
okay
nine
so which one's the nine and that one's
okay
so cool so like you may you made a
hot rock
do i do i want a rock yeah you're asking
me are you gonna ask me something yeah
but
that was was more real life stuff
okay um i mean
i i just think that uh
no i feel you like like think about your
life choices but okay so
hypothetically what makes somebody more
or less likely to think about their life
choices and how it impacts somebody else
um their socioeconomic conditions so on
nine like empathy you know
like if you're operating
yeah cool
okay cool just making sure
someone stoked
mine is good
i need weight so if i have used all my i
can build a
road
right that's how this works
okay
so
the question is
because and i just want to ask a
question
um if i build a road here would i be
able to put a settlement here yes yeah
but you're taking a risk
it is because he could also start
because if he's building up if he's
unlikely if he built well because if he
beats me to that spot he could build it
first is what you're saying so but if he
puts a road right here does that stop me
from being able to build the settlement
there then not the road the settlement
is what would keep you yeah you have a
head start you have to have two roads to
to another settlement okay so if he
builds a settlement before you that's
what would burn you
okay i mean
i like this i'll put a road right there
i think i mean i think uh
like we should all be in a state where
we can think about our lives and choose
the best course instead of being
panicked and
anxious
and surviving
yeah i just think
there are things that tend to make us
more anxious okay yeah cool certain news
networks might report certain things
that would make us more anxious
yeah like fox news
which is bad for the brain
what'd you vote
um
yeah i mean i think uh
we should be able to think about our
jobs and what choices we make without
you know
without like the threat of economic
uh
destitution and homelessness and
starvation
um
and uh
like
oh you're turning um a city
right i can do that
yeah two wheat
tui and three yeah
past my turn
can you pass the dice
thank you
i'm sorry i'm so used to magic the
gathering
uh what did they do there with the dust
because you don't want to hand anybody
anything usually
uh
i just feel like if people are forced to
work for survival and they know they
don't have to
and they're getting cheated then it
breeds resentment so then doesn't that
almost necessitate an argument for
capitalism then
yeah no but you skip on a building
yeah yeah okay if if working for
survival is what keeps people
so what i said i said that you shouldn't
work for survival because
then it increases uh
anxiety and stress mm-hmm
six yeah so because i have two
so do i get two of these then is that
what that means yeah one for each one
okay
i think people should be free to choose
whatever career they want
and not do it out of survival
and then we'll get the best out of them
it's kind of interesting um
okay so i can still like build on this
turn right yeah
okay so i go
i feel like i'm gonna build another
settlement right here
right
now and then if you have the money yeah
one word don't do it that way oh sorry
yeah that's it one bird one brick
one wheat
one sheep
and yeah that's it
ben's doing pretty good
but uh yeah i mean so now it's your turn
i uh yeah i just
just want everyone to contribute as much
as they can
at their own pace
like we're not dying we don't need
everyone to contribute at breakneck
speed
[Music]
okay so
yeah i'm gonna pass my turn
eleven
yep i didn't know that stress is like a
really interesting thing to study in
people because
there's this sort of optimal level of
performance that's supposedly achieved
so seven you said there's a weird thing
about a seven like enough stress is good
because there's no this is this is the
time i guess where we're gonna explain
that okay so you want to have a little
bit where's your little grain
like if you like say that there's stress
when there's not stress when it's
arbitrary
then i think that's
then it breathes distrust and
it makes the people not trust the system
so you get to move this guy and cover
one of these spots
and that means we can't collect from
there anymore until we move the robber
so any of these spots usually people
pick the red numbers because they're the
most valuable and you want to [ __ ] over
your opponents okay um
let me do
which one do i then you get to steal
from whoever you want
that's you that that's on the
okay so that you covered i'm gonna go
with
ether
we got some people bringing up the
electoral college which i love i love it
that's
is it
yeah i love it i mean i hate the
electoral college but i'm glad people
are bringing it up the electoral college
makes sure that all states are
represented equally that's a big deal
like giving them arbitrary number of
points oh yeah okay so i'm going here at
11.
yeah that's fine it's not a very big
number though it doesn't have a lot of
dots oh so you want to get a number with
more dots yeah go with here on this
eight sure
and then you get to steal from either me
or
i mean they're crazy what do you mean
yeah like you take one card take one
card from one of you guys yeah do i get
to see the card or do you notice you
just give me a so here's the thing is
yeah oh yeah yeah that's a good spot
because now you can choose from me or
hans
yeah um and obviously you want to pick
hans because he's the threat like he's
he's the man who's been like
manipulating this whole thing from the
beginning he's been telling both of us
what to do i know it's like really from
the goodness of his heart but at the end
of the day like his subconscious wants
him to win too you know
take from whatever
i have the most of if you need that but
if she has something that you need i got
i got three cats what you got what do
you guys have three cards as well but it
really doesn't matter how many cards we
have obviously honestly affirmative
action you should take my card
i hate you're playing this game uh three
cards
dude this is this is all about politics
i'm gonna steal from you take it
all right [ __ ] it i mean i really don't
care i'm just gonna take it yeah i don't
know i don't know what you're taking
either that's the fun
all right yeah it's my turn now yeah go
ahead i mean
do you think
of six do you think that the stress of
not amounting to anything in life is
enough stress to motivate you to do
stuff with your life
two
i need to stop rolling sixes it's what i
need to do i'm disappointing
a lot of things in life right now with
that behavior
i'm gonna
go ahead and pass my turn again okay
thank you and
thank you
the dice
you've trained me well six
again
another six yeah
so
do i offer trade before or after my turn
uh
after you roll okay after i wrong yeah
what do you want
okay uh i am offering
i'll give you a brick i will i
i will actually if you have rock i will
trade you wheat for rock
um
what about brick for rock
or a brook for wheat
you want brick no i want rock that's
what i want if anyone wants to give up a
rock i have plenty of wheat do you have
i'm willing to trade what about one rock
for one weight and one
uh
uh
wood
okay so you give me two rocks i give you
one no i'll give you one rock one rock
for one wood and one wheat yeah
what about one rot for two wheat
one rock for two wheat no i need a wood
if you want one rock
this is tense
i love it
[Laughter]
i'm here for the tension the drama the
austin drama all right
real world austin
i already have enough of it settling the
only thing that you're looking for is
wheat and wood
i what about three wheat for
two for two rocks
i only can give you one rock okay what
about three wheats for one rock
three wheats
i need a wood
so
what about one wood for one rock
and then a brick for a wheat
i can give you one rock and one brick
i don't need break
this is good to have what about if you
give me
one sheep
and you give me one what wood and one
i'll give you one wood and one weed for
one rock and one sheep
no i can't do it sorry
yeah okay
i'm gonna trade this in for one week
unless you can give me wait so you can
trade what are you saying three bricks
for one anything that's on here
on the left side
is the
cost
and on the right side is what it will
gain you but what i'm saying is like but
are you trading in like three bricks so
the cost goes into the bank
and then you automatically get what is
on the right side because he's asking a
specific question i don't understand
what you mean you can trade in four of
any resources and for any one of any
resource four of any resource for any
one of any reason yeah
oh
i told you this in the beginning you did
i i think i didn't understand you didn't
understand it but i just wanted
the record to state that if if he needs
to go back on his turn if he needs to do
a time machine real quick we can make
that happen
i'm not asking oh do you want you want
this much
brick no
i don't want that okay
all right
here you go
okay
so
i can roll
six six okay so
i get
brick the sizes
and success for
x's to eat
okay
so you can trade in so at any time i can
trade 74 right yeah
don't you think like being a teacher is
a good job
and that can i do more than it makes you
better than some people
can i tell you a story about my lyft
driver tonight
was he creepy or a racist i no
no my lyft driver was a young woman
who was about my age
who
was a teacher here in austin
and also tonight i got out to see a show
um
okay so can i trade this for one rock
one two three four for one rock you just
put it right here i guess i'm alright
yeah okay cool and i'll take a rock can
i still build if i do that or not yeah
okay you can build as much as you want
so you can build as much as you want so
your lyft driver was
doing something he was shin enough
okay
now
can i
it's like a
so the only road that i can technically
build on
is like i can either build
um
like going this way like two roads here
yeah or i can build like going this way
but i can't build
like the build here okay i see
you can build here you can build here
you can build here okay i connected that
you get built here that's a good spot
can
okay i see yeah that makes sense
okay so built here
into the
if you make a triangle then you don't
have to build as many roads
but
like this is a good spot
oh yeah you're just going to egg him
over into my territory that's cool
so you asked me being a teacher is a
good job so my lyft driver tonight and
i got out to see
one of my best friends
growing up
um this dude lived two doors down for me
yeah and he was playing a show
his band's workshop billy and the voice
and they're sick
but like he would he okay i'm gonna
build right there had a license to be a
teacher this woman had a license to be a
teacher they both went into the schools
out here in austin
yeah and i mean i'm i'm speaking from
somebody who teaches in massachusetts
and like the statistics are most people
that go into teaching quit
three yep
within their first three to five years
of teaching right
so
i'm gonna pass my turn
i mean that's in america right yeah it's
it's burnout
like so what do you want me to sell you
it's a noble great career where you
should go and burn yourself out and like
there's no realistic way to do it under
capitalism like so you're you're the
only one oh this thing's blocked off
okay yeah yeah
good that you're doing it
but i get two out of this because of
city
okay
it's difficult but you do it anyways
because it's such a good job but the
thing about that is that the rest of the
planet banks on that like the way that
these
like uh you know
first response and like first hand and
wait through
people were dealt with over covey like
the hand they got dealt like yeah
so they get to pay you less because
it's some a good thing that people
actually want to do
so they're like oh people will naturally
be attracted to this so you don't have
to be it's a female dominated career
yeah
whatever that means but
it means it's
they bank on people not demanding
better working conditions for themselves
and the children and women are easier
because they don't have political power
to disenfranchise
okay so i'm going to change this until
it develops the city
you're just going to let him do that
yeah
okay yeah that's very really i told you
we created one two three four five
points okay so then making the best out
of a bad board
you want to use up a lot of your cards
because if you have over seven then you
lose them
you have to discard what is it half your
hand round it up yeah if you're over
seven if somebody rolls a seven
and you have more than seven cards in
your hand
then that's good okay but you probably
want to be under that under right we're
gonna roll it around again well does
anyone want to trade for any uh wheat
for some wood or sheep
well since you have too many cards what
i will do for you
is i will trade you one wood for two
wheat
one wood for two weeks yeah you need to
get some cards off your hand let me help
you first of all you're being a savage
and you drive a hard bargain but if i
make this trade can i still play a turn
on this yeah yeah okay
i will then accept your offer one word
for two weeks
okay and then
i will use that weed and a brick and i
will build a road
you know what
does anyone want to trade any
does anyone want to trade for a sheep
yeah what do you need
um oh wait i would like a sheep oh you
would like a sheep okay yeah
i would like for you to give me a sheep
i want you to give me sheep
very nice nice sheep
all right so there's not really anywhere
i can use to build two roads right now
um
i mean like it sucks that there isn't a
lot of money in teaching
it's just it's not even the money it's
literally like coveted i will skip this
term
like i went into my
building and
i had no ppe
i had no hand sanitizer
so i'm just like uh with an eight yeah
acting weirdly unnaturally as like a
public safety person and like i'm not
being given any guidance or any tools
like it's just
it's not my job i want to do a good job
i don't want my kids to get sick i don't
want their families to get sick
yeah and of course it burns people out
like
it's an inherently abusive system
i wouldn't i wouldn't recommend it to
anyone
so i
appreciate the [ __ ] out of it
sure but if you're living in an ideal
system
like don't you think that would be a
very rewarding job okay sure so
if we were living in an ideal system
wouldn't it be nice to be a
hedge phone broker no
for like in an ideal system you want to
be staring at computers all day
i'd rather be playing with kids than
like are you making a move or i am i'm
just also being interrogated
intellectually right now i love it
get on your toes
hurts
okay i love it too i'm gonna
pop some tags who wants to give me a
sheet i've been i have whatever it is
that you want for your sheep but um
somebody give me a sheep
i don't have it
i got no sheep for you man
you guys are a bunch of sheep okay you
know what you're all just an assistant
man
so
um anybody want to trade me like wood
for um
a rock
that'd be cool
what a rock does anybody want to give me
a rock i'll give you wood i don't have
any rock a rock for something
how much wood
how much wood would a woodchuck chuck if
a woodchuck could chuck wood
well okay now that you mentioned brick
yeah speak on it
yeah no you know what yeah no i'm just
i'll go back to my
previous offer all right nobody wants us
okay go ahead so um
what what do you think about that guy
that when i was trying to park and i was
having a tough time and it was
criticized wow
and then
he was standing in the parking spot that
was just hans what did you think about
that
i thought he was just like
purely existing as a being in that
moment just to like play a role in what
he thinks
so can you can you explain the full
situation for folks then so i was trying
to park in a spot and i was having a
tough time doing it and people were
getting mad at me wait why were you
having a tough time parking in your spot
because i have a huge fan you have a
huge fan yeah and you were lining your
huge man up with the lines of the
parking space where you know
and then people were yelling at wait why
were people yelling at you though
because i was doing it in a super
insecure way you it was your fault that
you were parking your van between the
lines of a parking space no i'm allowed
to park and okay spaces so why was it
difficult for you to park in that
parking space when you went to go park
in it there's a big old van and a small
little spot and so these people were
yelling at me it had nothing to do with
the fact that somebody intentionally
came and stood inside of your parking
spot yeah so they they saw this struggle
prohibited from parking there this guy
decided and then just made aggressive
eye contact with you why you tried to
park
it was intense but yeah i mean and i
didn't really couldn't really understand
a reason for it because they were
parked comfortably in their spot and
then just did not want you to be able to
park
they wanted to yell at someone and they
were like look at this guy he's showing
me you trying to park in your parking
spot i can now attack someone who's
showing weakness
that's one of my favorite things to do
so we will i roll a nine yeah okay so
one would okay
so there's one
all right so i'm gonna do a couple of
things here aria
yeah so first things first
so how'd you feel about it yeah you just
i just felt like he's like a poor dude
like economically and also like this is
how he gets his kicks off he just is
actually tough in a parking lot but at
some point it bothers me like if he's
doing that and it's like i'm only a a
monkey you know like if you like give
someone a grape and give me a cucumber
i'm going to throw it yeah an incentive
so i'm going to build a development
right so
it was infuriating but it was like cool
to share a real moment with him there
cool um and then it takes but yeah it's
just uncomfortable and inefficient but
you know at least he's communicating
that's that's a city what's up you you
paid for a settlement so but
you
you uh you paid for
one of these guys so then you put it
right here oh okay that's a supplement
if you want to buy that oh that's the
settlement though or if you want to
convert it to a city you pay this yeah
i'm sorry i just i had it backwards okay
you're good um and then what i wanted to
do
yeah it was really it was like
manufactured intensity and it was like
it's like manufactured drama he's like
he just wants drama he just wants to
kill something yep yep
yeah yeah
but he didn't look very
well nourished it looked like honestly
you're pretty selfish on new years to
deprive him of that you really just
should have put your face in front of
his fists and just really gotten it
started for new year's just giving him a
good
space to beat up on man this asian guy
came up on me
and he was
honestly
you never know
forgot some kung fu or something i don't
know you know yeah
man this asian girl was being a [ __ ]
and i beat his ass
i don't know what
how that could have gone
okay well for him
oh
[ __ ] you [ __ ] okay
a monster
one wood and one all right cool
okay so come on i see
the
is your turn
you should roll the dice yes i should
roll
um but yeah i mean
what are you going to do for the new
year
i mean the new year's already here
what are you going to do for it though
okay so here's a question about the six
so because i have it here does that mean
i get three
yes with that okay god damn it
he's got i really need to that's what i
need to start doing my new years to stop
rolling sixes for you [ __ ]
i don't know if that's how dies work
all right
uh okay so uh would anyone like to trade
me
a sheep would anybody like to give to me
a sheep for your
what do you want wildest dreams um for
one sheep
how would you feel about i'll give you a
whole
uh i'll give you a hole
um
um
hey
hey yeah no no hey what about rock what
do you got for rock
i will give you one sheep for two give
you i'll give you two hey
two rock i'll give you
two
uh logs
would
give you my wood i'll give you two wood
for that sheet
hmm
new
one hay and one what
i don't like it what about one
rock and one wood
can't
[Music]
yeah sorry dude i i really wanted to
make a deal but uh yeah yeah wait a
second oh i only grabbed three wheat i
didn't even realize i can grab
one brick
cool
yeah so i'll
i'll trade somebody for
brick
if somebody wants to give me a break
i'll uh what would you give up for for a
break what
yeah
thanks yeah bud oh
yeah don't help ben out you don't like
winning
we need to trade with each other you
have three points i have four points are
you guys trying to communism out of this
game yeah oh my god what capitalism
we're monopolizing the market you really
teach me about putting your house there
but so i'm gonna
that was not the time for petty
grievance
oh man dude that was not the time for
petty grievances
why don't you save up and build a
settlement right there yeah i really
love that for me
go ahead
yeah
i love it by the way i love this ass it
is the pretty most ass quality right now
seven
yes [ __ ] [ __ ] over ben
this is the best way
stealing from you okay dude
don't take it personally just fan your
cards out and i'll take one all right
but hold on i want to mix my cards up
take what you want from me you have a
wood
that's not what you took
wood
you're asking me oh did you do a thing
yeah i can give you rock for wood
you can give me rock for wood okay be
careful who you help hannah because you
think you're gonna [ __ ] me over but
you're gonna make a [ __ ] powerhouse
out of this savage i'm aware of what i'm
doing right now but i also am very
petty and i don't know why but i kind of
have it out for you tonight well that's
fair i mean listen if you want to take
an l to help this monster win you can
thank you
i'm not a monster i'm a human being with
feelings i know a monster when i see
when you're not fooling
me um anyone have sheep for brick
yeah
oh whoa i see what you did there
all right so like um what was it was
like your favorite movie of like 20 21
no no yeah for sheep for a rock i don't
have a rock 2021 yeah
i don't know last year what was your
favorite movie the website this year
was it was 2020. okay my favorite movie
that i saw recently was i didn't even
see it yet but the i will re-watch the
spider-man series with the newest guy
tom hall okay yeah the all the tom
hollands except for the newest one did
you like that that's pretty good i like
the tom holland ones actually but the
best spider-man i will down this hill is
into the spot actually i want to buy one
more thing he's into the spider verse uh
it is spider versus you convinced me of
that very quickly you just keep letting
the savage buy everything but i'm the
monster that you need to find off okay
uh i think i want to do this
wow you can't build
okay yeah we should really do something
about that so you just build a road to
block me from building a road yeah
longest road i was just about to say
okay
wow
so making problems
all right
i guess i like bad [ __ ] that's my
[ __ ] problem i guess
just making problems for me to be haters
i like it do you think
okay so we got a three
what does that mean if we get a three
okay clearly so i can get a
two rock
cool
um what else came out it was a tough
year from movies
i was just the pandemic is there anyone
willing to trade a rock that's that's
james bond you know they killed james
bond off no spoiler alert okay no
problem
they killed james bond off in the latest
james bond
that was crazy that never happens how do
you kill james bond off yeah
but james bond still can't be a woman
though
so what is the development card and what
do they have to do with the game they
like you they give you random [ __ ]
manipulate the game in your favor that's
really the best way to all-encompass
english so my
i just haven't had the ability to you
should if you can
i feel like you guys are all setting me
up for you guys are trying to trick me
but you know what
you got to use up those cards you have
to do it
i'm going to get one of these
development cards
develop your breasts
i'm trying to dude okay so that's one
sheep
one rock
and one wheat and i grabbed a
development so what do you think about
cancel culture
okay
what does it say because a lot of people
what do you think about cancer
don't tell us oh i don't tell them yeah
well
so here's the thing about those cards is
if you read it carefully you'll figure
out when it is appropriate to play the
card this is when her teacher side comes
out
did you read the instructions
you can't use it this turn i can't use
it this time yeah you gotta wait for the
next turn oh okay say less all right fam
cool cool you gonna buy anything else
[Music]
because i feel like a lot of cancer
culture is just like no i'm not having
standards as a society go ahead do you
trust the government to uh
regulate censorship
uh yes i do
i don't trust our government right now
okay yeah so
why did you just grab a card 12. oh oh
there's another 12. there's another 12.
where's the other total that's the other
12. yeah okay
anyway there's some cards for you
anybody want to give me a sheep
it would be so cool
i need a sheep
yeah
i will not make any deals with you now
just kidding i don't have any sheep
thank you or maybe i do and i'm just a
hater
this one honestly i wouldn't say yes
a seven yeah so you're gonna choose the
robbery
so do you have to move it or can you
leave it
i have to move it okay
four
that's four
i think brick is more precious than wood
for some reason i think that i don't
know why oh and you also have a brick
port
so you can trade two bricks in for any
one of anything
okay so
all right well you could take two bricks
in for any one of anything you can let
me steal from you wait okay all right
i can't steal a development card so you
don't have to shuffle the development
card okay oh because it shows up so it's
not like the same as other cards
okay
anyone have sheep
so two bricks for any one of anything
first of all this is great
i'm glad you're happy and well let me
know when your turn is up because
i'm so excited to play my next turn
she's very excited you have sheep anyone
have sheep no an issue okay i'm gonna do
this
ah this is savage
named hans king so when you roll the
dice first and then you can start
playing your cards yeah no you can play
a development card right away
you need more water
so good thank you uh so development card
uh move the robber steal one resource
from the owner of a settlement or city
adjacent to the robber's new hex
say less fam you can put that in front
of yourself all right so i'm gonna play
that i'm gonna move the robber back to
where it belongs over here
and then i'm going to steal a card from
hans
it's all the same
is it yeah i know exactly what i'm
getting then
perfect say less i just wanted that back
i needed that all right so now i'm going
to roll
yeah cancel culture
yeah i'm gonna cancel your robbery you'd
rather have the government regulating
censorship and speech than
okay the masses the people
so when has government ever canceled
someone that's a nine
cancelled decently like the cancer
culture republicans are talking about is
all like media based and like okay
recently
uh jazlane maxwell
okay thank you
i just mean that
if you're gonna
be america you cancel people all the
time
uh
i definitely think you should have
freedom jennings v rodriguez was like
people who
are undocumented there in the country
don't have the right to bail and they
don't have the right to a lawyer and
they don't have the right to habeas
scorpius like
what
that's not cancel culture that's
immigration law yeah but that's
literally just
pretending that people don't exist when
the 14th amendment says that all people
haven't got equal rights to the law
anyone yeah i mean i don't support that
at all
should be more i would love to take a
sheep from you would none of us have
sheep okay then i'm
all right
come on as you were
wait a second
nobody's got cheap huh you should use
your cards yeah if no one's got sheep
then i'm probably gonna make a move here
um
government
um i think is
should be totally democratic
we should just vote directly without it
so because you put it here
because because you put it here i can't
build
i can't build anything yeah you can
build
but like so i could put like a road road
in the house right there no because
they're so close to this okay
that was my ass like that was my
question okay so then what i could do
though
is
make that a road and make it the longest
contiguous road i can't
you can build two roads here you can
build two roads here
you could block my road because but you
can't put a house here though right
because
yeah i can't build a house there okay
so what's the point of building like the
longest road like how does that happen
oh you get two points out of it this is
what i got
this car goes to play with the longest
road or at least five segments i mean i
think there has to be some sort of
standards and decorum in society so five
segments does the house do what the
house count is the segment or what does
that mean yeah the house is just a part
of it the roads let's just count the
roads one two three four five six but
even if i block your road here it's
still going to be the longest contiguous
way yeah but it would stop me yeah but
any road i built won't be longer than
that from there well you could build
longer than that from there
it'd be hard it'd be very hard but what
i could do
is
build
one road please can you pay for it first
sure
[Music]
i think that
we should be like hey maybe we shouldn't
say that uh you know like
uh
transgender people should be
uh you know
uh
kicked out of uh
i don't know i don't know why i built it
maybe saying like gay people need to be
strung up uh and murdered is not like
something we should accept as a society
and if you say that there should be
consequences
and that no one wants to hang out with
you oh no it's your turn
10 10.
where's the other ten
so that's
uh
[Music]
okay
what you gonna do when they come for you
oh um
um
does anyone have a sheep
no
no
does anybody have a rock
no it depends what you're offering for
it two
uh
hey
do we
nope
uh
three weeks
nope
uh
wood brick
and wheat for one rock i will give you
wood for a rock
yeah
what about a wood and a sheep
i can't give you sheep because i don't
have any sheep ah
don't have me a sheep
so you have to be at the airport at six
no
we just have to leave here at six to go
back to my place okay right at the
airport
i have 32 more minutes yeah okay
yeah i'm glad that
it's happening eleven
three
wait a second okay so yeah wait so what
straw man arguing were you asking me
again
cancel culture
so what i'm gonna do so i get to
rock and i'm gonna the government has
just been really on the wrong side of a
lot of things when it comes to
censorship they've tried to stop people
from getting information out about birth
control they've
been complicit in trying to
get people to
divest from unions
like
and
have absolutely put people in jail for
anything that remotely resembled
anything that had to do with socialism
or communism or used as
obviously like okay
you made a good point that if there are
algorithms that can find all kinds of
[ __ ]
yeah it's your turn enough that's
serious two three four five six seven
three
three
i mean i don't think that it's good to
censor people
um
but uh
i think
that um
we should be educated enough where we
don't have to be censored
but that's the it's like this catch-22
with that like scenario right because
there's this on one side where you're
like
i don't want to be censored i think the
average person should be smart enough to
where they should be able to take in all
the information possible and then they
should be able to make decisions based
off of the knowledge and the know-how
that they have as like educated members
of society but then there's also this
other part of it that looks at it like
there's so much power concentrated in
the hands of sophie and when it comes to
things like media and like the
dissemination of information
that if you're giving this kind of like
free
of rain on people to create that it's
just it's it's overwhelming for the
average person
um and yeah so it's like where do you
draw the line between what works
yeah i think the best way is to give the
power to the people and democratically
vote and see what we all agree about but
not when it comes to censorship
yeah when it comes to censorship we
should all vote and decide like
but isn't that just what cancel culture
is people voting on yeah that's why i'm
saying that some of it is good that's
been my point the whole time
okay so it's my turn yeah are you still
about to build yeah
anyone have sheep
okay i'm done i guess
but uh i mean it's it's like
the majority think that something is the
case like should we have put all the
japanese
or should we have done red scare if
everyone agreed to it
eleven
i uh
it depends on a case-by-case basis but i
think like hopefully the answer is no
like you shouldn't censor people based
on their beliefs of politics
but um if it's like an imminent threat
then i think that it's okay i mean i
don't i think that you should be allowed
to say gay people should be able to be i
think you should be able to say that gay
people should be murdered and tortured
and bruised and beaten
um but i think that you should also be
allowed to boycott someone who says that
there's got to be consequences for the
for what people do there's got to be
consequences for people's actions
i do think that's that's the weird thing
about censorship is that like even if i
don't agree with somebody i have to
imagine that i have to believe that i
they have the right to say it even if i
don't agree with it like or else that
goes against everything i stand for
right like if you're just like trying to
censor people because they disagree with
you because that's a lot of what people
are trying to do like you can't say this
because they're saying something and
they're like oh this is dangerous but
then it's like if you have a segment of
the population or half of the
populations that believe this is
dangerous and the other populated
segment of the population that believes
this is true then the disconnect isn't
with like those people that believe the
disconnect is how you can have one idea
be so widely
either accepted or discredited like
that's the disconnect right not so much
more problems so many people believe it
i mean but that's the thing if
somebody believes it right and someone
thinks it is but that's just all based
on subjective beliefs yes there's
nothing objective or concrete that makes
people think some one way or the other
it's just their their subjective beliefs
right that's what i think is the bigger
disconnect is how far apart people are
in that spectrum
yeah
i'm done i'm almost out on my turn yeah
i rolled the 11 right no i wrote the
election okay so it's your turn
i mean i think that we shouldn't say
horrible things about people but you
should be able to and
then you should be able to be punished
for it as well
um but sometimes like people think that
something is bad when it's not actually
that bad
and then you over cancel someone like
justine sacco
who tweeted i'm going to africa hope i
don't get aids
and then she got cancelled
uh and people just got had made had fun
cancelling her so i think that's when
it's not good when it's just like for
fun
but
i think that there was like a time when
canceling actually used to like do like
it was weird because they didn't cancel
celebrities back then they just
cancelled random people that like made
tweets which was [ __ ] up
yeah like being dad we still do that
does anybody have any break
no okay
being dad's this guy that was like i
made my daughter figure out how to open
up a can with a can opener without
telling her how and that's why i'm such
a good dad is because i made her learn
things without telling her helping her
in any way and people were like boo
that's stupid you should feel bad we
hate you
it's just funny i guess
a lot of haters in the building
um
anyone have brick
we're all really hurting right now would
you roll
eight
no love on the ochos you know brick um
you have wood
what are you throwing first what are you
offering for what rock
what happens when there's only one wood
and like i'm supposed to get two there's
a bunch of right here
a bunch of wood you want a rock for that
wood
yep
thank you
one two three four
one two three
see what you did there
well played hans
well played hans zinner
like i mean sometimes the crowd can be
wrong but what else do we have about
each other
four
four
i just uh
the
the march on
the capitol really kind of like made me
start questioning whether i wanted
government censorship or not
watching people marching around with
like six million was not enough shirts
it was
pretty wild
does anyone know six experience that
does anyone want to trade
yeah i mean there's some hay
we should uh
wait a second can i even do that i mean
like a chinese style surveillance or
like a british style surveillance i
think it's inevitable you want hay you
want my hay
hmm well i'm trying to see
yeah there's a lot of
places that are already doing it which
is pretty unfortunate
yeah
but as long as it's completely
democratically controlled
i think it's very
i will trade you difficult for people i
will charge you [ __ ] questions i will
trade you for hey
what do you want for one hate
oh i will give you hay i don't need hay
okay
yeah you want me okay i'll take a hay
what do you want for it what do you want
for it what do i want for it i want
uh don't trade with him i'm on a sheep
he's winning yeah
i will give you a sheep for her hey
don't trade with him or he might win
okay so it's one
wood
one one
brick
one hey
and one
shot and eight points now for
development
settlement for some right there
calling everything at development
uh yeah i don't know i don't know where
that term came from but i just i feel it
very strongly
right for the development card
probably
all right uh i guess it's yeah that's
the end of my turn
all right
so yeah that's
three
okay
can i only use this once
this development card yeah yeah they
bring it back every time you move it a
little throwback from the 90s a little
card that i played
already
uh does anybody have
any brick they can trade to me
no no
what about
fur
rock no i know
you guys really don't have any
i will
turn
a
city
will you trade with me
thank you
um
so why do you think we have less sex
than
other generations
i thought about this a lot
uh
i think it's got
i think there's a lot of factors
obviously
but eleven i think it's more so
prevalent um one of the factors though
that i would find to see very
like how that plays is how
i think there's a general mistrust now
comparative to the past i think more
information
has kind of led to there's more
it's more like frowned upon societally
almost in terms of like
it's just more out there in the open a
lot more consequences and fear that are
managed with it so i think there's
that and you just combined that i think
like younger generations are going out
less they're
still living at home longer they're
making less money buying having kids
later like i feel like all those factors
just contribute to us [ __ ] lives so
like economically we're poor and we're
not sexy
being broke has never been sexy bro
knows i've been like yo are you broke
come [ __ ] me like we're living in like
the most richest time ever and we don't
even get to enjoy it well how do you
measure that but like riches is relative
right because they say there's more
money but if you look at how much more
concentrated that is the average person
exactly richer there's more money for a
select few but not everybody so if we
could spread it out we'd be [ __ ] more
i hope so six
oh you guys blocked my six
so do i get just one break
i mean is that all it takes is just
money and then we'll start [ __ ]
i don't think it's just that but i do
think that um
that like
just that kind of general sense i feel
like the more independence you take away
from people and that kind of leads to
that so in the sense that there's just
there's there's kind of less freedom
less independence in general and that's
kind of
led to this does anyone want any wood
anyone need any wood
no
don't trade without he's so close he's
got eight points
um but yeah i mean i think it's
like mostly that
and like i also think like we're very
divided now and it's tough to come
together
when things are like so contentious
it's pretty crazy how like
what real quick question would i have
any benefit in building a road that
connects these two right now there'd be
no benefit to that yeah i mean you'd
have one two three four five six seven
i have one two three four five six oh
actually
if you did that that would give you the
longest road and give you two points
one two three four five six seven
yeah but you'd also
yeah would those two points be enough to
end the game
do you have it
if you have it you should do it
and then just end the game
yeah there's a
i mean if you have it there's no reason
to drag it out it's kind of cruel
actually no i i don't have it if i have
oh thank god i already had it but
okay so now we know that he's that close
to building the longest road so i'll
finish my road is it your tournament oh
it's your turn you rolled the six
so what you're the six i did row six on
maybe you can talk me into it though
don't let it win
i guess you have to go home soon but
could i which way could i block your
road
well i guess you can make it longer each
way two three okay i have to have all
three
okay
um pass on the rest of my turn
bye
all right
who
[Music]
wants to trade me a brick
for rock
yeah
thank you thanks
all right
[Music]
okay
i'm gonna settle
oh
i need
a road to do that no you don't
no i do
yeah i mean if you build here you can't
because it's too close to mine that's
true
that doesn't help me
because i need sheep
so
uh oh but you know what nope okay yep
can continue okay
i mean that's a lot of cards so i would
hate for a seven to get rolled yeah
honestly it just needs to happen
i think i got missed already
okay so uh
what who's your favorite evolution
revolutionary
uh
you could like have like pom-poms and
like a cheerleading team okay yeah cool
yeah that is very charismatic and very
peaceful
did you uh
did you watch any of the new watchmen
series
no
i wish
you should do it
find somebody with hbo
tell them they're cute get their get
their password
uh anyone have
rock
and watch sheep
multiple sheeps
no one wants sheep
and i will trade you for
[Music]
one sheep and one hay
i can't do it sorry
okay i will trade you one like i'm not
trading with you okay fine
because i'm racist that's bad
um
yeah i mean okay who's your favorite
revolutionary hans would you be a
teacher would you do it yeah would you
teach teacher what age would you teach
them what would you teach
um so probably like middle school
and probably
to break
i would teach like
okay math
or history hans why don't you teach
middle school math because i'm trying to
do a comedy thing we need you
um because you joined the ranks also you
said two group gets you two brick gets
you one of two brick gets you one of
anything right yeah
okay
i mean i think like
teaching is very therapeutic and like
it's a natural part of
uh
hunter-gatherer tribes and societies
yeah and it's like yeah it's super
necessary
yeah are you about to win right now
probably did we really just teach this
man how to play yes thank you guys
i think you guys are cooked i don't know
how i want to do this but i think you
guys are about to lose i'm going to
trade these two bricks for a
hey
all right so i'm going to do that
he lost the true meaning of katana
that's friendship
you know what's friendly is winning um
okay so then i'm going to build enough
to vocalize it so hold on um but yeah i
mean
i remember my first time i won katan
i've never played before so one break
yeah i mean i won one i did that too
one on my first time it's pretty pretty
crazy there's a road
here
and then one brick one two three four
five six seven
there's a road there one two three four
five six seven eight oh yes eight and
there's another
[Music]
did you answer who your favorite
revolutionary was one brick
one
that one sheep so then i can use
that
i love
that
that and that malcolm x is good too i
was gonna say malcolm x but it's not
malcolm x
one two three hydra lord probably who's
that
so if i build she was bad if i were to
put a thing right there that'd give me
seven right in the longest road no
what you don't have a longest road you
can't do it anymore you're lying i
connected it yeah you connected it okay
cool one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
nine we need ten roads okay and then i'm
going to
he has nine points right now
we have to defeat him
this is so classic then right now one
two three four five six
what can i do
okay so
simplest thing i can do right now
is going to be
she doesn't have any wheat
because the robbers on it
yeah so as soon as someone rolls a seven
it's over for you snitches
[Music]
he barely has any rock
don't worry about my rock game girl rock
game strong but
somebody said frank hansen that's pretty
legit i love fred hampton
bro i'm a big fred hampton fan
he was born on the day fred hampton died
nice all right i've traveled across the
country okay all right oh my god it's
nina simone that's the end of my turn go
ahead i love nina is she like a song
nina simone what yeah is she a song no
i don't know
what did you get
sex
all night i have been rolling you
[ __ ] sex you guys are all
ungrateful
thank you
um
i am because you took my sick so and you
get nothing for me i didn't give you i
didn't do it yeah that's hard
we're all the same i didn't know i
deserved all this okay uh so anybody
feel bad enough to get me like
what break i can give you break okay
what do you what do you want to trade
for bear i will give you
uh wheat for free yeah okay you could
trade with hans and let homs win
he's at nine points but hans is gonna
creep up that's how it always works
you're so focused on me hans creeps
through the back door right uh-huh look
at hans i don't want either of you in my
backstory to be honest
hanzo has seven points don't he's done
like he's not about to win and he's at
nine points as well because he's got
i will take
i'm not i'm at eight points
what's up i'll take birth from you too
oh [ __ ] yeah
well i thought you were trying to join
big hater
okay trade with odds that okay okay
okay
so i'm gonna road
and i'm gonna settle
it's what i do every day
oh wait wait okay wait yeah okay
i love revolutionaries because people
like you can't change the system you're
only one person but then it's like these
people did it
and it's like that way nothing gets
changed if everyone's just thinking
about themselves
and trying to live their best
shuttle
okay
then i'm gonna trade in three of
these
four
so it's three wheat two brick
for anything
and then four free of anything for one
of anything if you have a house on one
of those
yeah you get two sheep for one of it
okay that's why mine is two brick
because i have a house here for
so do i get two to one rock for one of
anything to them yeah okay oh [ __ ] oh i
didn't know that well you just got that
yeah so i i just yeah no i didn't know
that's how that that's where that came
from so that makes sense
okay
ten
[Music]
it doesn't sound like your [ __ ]
sociopath at all that is such
a monotone whistle i i'm uh dang what a
hater
[Laughter]
we're not blinking three times for help
you had uh brick what's up
i'm all set oh no you want sheep
i'm all set thank you okay
let's play
knight
steal from ben right here
ah actually
i really don't want to move that but if
you play it you got to use it right
right now
okay
i don't care i was just like it's bold
to play it and then be like nah i don't
want to use that all right dude whatever
you want to do
do you think i should what do you think
all i'm gonna say is it's six o'clock
boys so
it's well we got four minutes
business let's keep okay i'll [ __ ]
play that wow to defeat the huns
yeah you knew where i was going with
that
um all right can you see my cards yeah
yeah
let me shuffle them dirty rotten cheese
good for you we're gonna catch on no
hold on i'm not done shuffling
yeah did you learn to say that
wow
that's crazy where did you learn to say
that um
i don't know i think it's funny
it seems very
should be
yeah you [ __ ] up honestly you [ __ ]
up hans like okay so i get three wheat
and
so what's this day can you finish the
road no well the game's gonna end before
six
the game's gonna yeah and get it
together right now get it good because i
have nine points right yeah yeah you
have three rock in two weeks this is
honestly so embarrassing i'm so sorry
for everyone back home in massachusetts
that's watching me let this man win
right now this is noob
right that's what it is two bricks
i get one rock
and then i have one two okay rock
we're close
and that puts me
a [ __ ] development in this business
a city i'm sorry i don't want to say
these words and i believe that is 10
points
and that is the ball game sir good game
sir good game all before sex
i'm not impressed
god damn um honestly hans it was really
nice to meet you i'm glad we're friends
now yeah i'm disowning them as a friend
i'm kind of pissed that he won
honestly like he's never gonna shut up
you're gonna we're gonna stay in touch
and i'm gonna need you
like i'm gonna need to live vicariously
through you when you get your revenge
game on him we're gonna gang up on ben
this is a [ __ ]
going through step by step everything
he's doing every turn me yeah well i
don't know
y'all like gave me a rough estimate of
the game yeah we taught you enough to
win relax oh yeah we did you
oh it's not our fault that we taught you
in the world you guys really taught a
kid how to parallel park 15 minutes
before his [ __ ] which is crazy
because you don't even you're a woman
how do you know how to parallel park
well that's true i actually just lied
about it
but then i emotionally manipulated the
guy who's giving the kid the test so it
worked out great nice you were in the
car with them
yeah that's how it works and ass
you gotta have the adult who's letting
you borrow the car in the car really
yeah
that's crazy
that ruins the whole experience yes i'm
gonna go run and use the restroom real
quick i'll be able to leave your
children alone with strangers and cars
that's the best way to do that i'm
pretty sure that's the law all right
yeah
how are else are you supposed to get sex
ed and drivers that didn't work okay
i'll do that in my city
well you could if you no we just have
driver's ed
be alone one-on-one
nah that's actually not true we got a
sex ed pass this year
in massachusetts
in uh the city that i'm in massachusetts
is city by city whereas district by
district you get to choose yeah that's
so cool
you have to decide if you want it's like
so you can dress up your uh citizens
with different rights it's really cute
yeah mix and match
yeah i mean hopefully we can all educate
and evolve past conservative
christianism so what's your favorite
board game
katan really yeah have you tried the new
dune board game yet no okay well
you shouldn't
nothing new i'd love to there's like a
story one that i would not i haven't
played yet i wouldn't say i wouldn't
have done it but
the doomboard game said it's like if
settlers of the time and magic the
gathering had a baby
nice
and then that baby punched you in the
face
damn i should have kept that
[ __ ] robber on that six
yeah
but you know i'm definitely your thrive
we were allied against ben for most of
that game yeah that was so bad that we
just let our name put us on the offense
like that
yeah ben thinks like he's awesome now as
if he needs more of that
why do you why do you hate my
mother
like my
general sense of confidence yes because
i mean your confidence
oh yeah like you don't spend all your
time trying to destroy our confidence i
don't try to destroy anyone's confidence
i try to build it up no you don't
not if you're competing i'm never
competing against anyone i'm always just
competing against myself
no you're not
when you're playing basketball you're
directly competing with other people not
really because the thing about when i'm
playing basketball is the only way to
best the only thing i can do is play
basketball to the best of my ability i
can't play better than i am well all you
have to do is play better than your
opponent so you're competing with your
opponent but that's not how you get
better i'm always just trying to play
against myself right but you're also
competing with someone else and you
enjoy beating other people
otherwise you wouldn't enjoy competition
right i do enjoy bitch-ass [ __ ] if you
don't enjoy compliments i do enjoy a
competition i'm not gonna pretend but
it's not like in a hateful way i don't
like wish bag upon you i just wish that
i do better right and if you can get
into people's head and make them lose
confidence in themselves you can win so
why wouldn't you do that because i don't
care about playing like mind games with
people like that but
you when people try to play mind games
with you yes you like playing mind games
back with them absolutely like that's
the thing i won't start talking trash i
won't start trying to get at people's
heads but if someone tries to come at me
with that like best believe i will play
this game and we will compete on that
level and you like playing that game i
do but only with people that want to
play i'm not going to say you're like
robin hood you only do it out of the
goodness of your heart
that's not out of the goodness of my
heart it's just someone offered a match
it's very good it's like you don't it's
like it's like there's like a code among
thieves you know like if someone's not
in the game you're not playing with them
it's but if someone wants to play this
game like they accept the terms of
conditions of talking [ __ ] like you
didn't talk [ __ ] this game no i didn't
talk any [ __ ] yeah because you were
interested in playing and just yeah i
was just playing and no one talks [ __ ]
everyone played so i didn't say anything
we just played basketball but like
because they didn't they didn't do the
the the societal contract of like
starting to talk [ __ ] and playing that
game if someone would have then i'm like
okay we can do this too but if they
don't i don't care enough to do that but
if they want to play that game i'll play
it too i'm game for any competition all
right sorry that i assumed that well huh
so how do i follow you dj hans kim
on what
uh instagram
okay
uh is this on
are you streaming this on youtube
just youtube does it live stream or do
you upload it later
i live stream it and upload it later oh
it's not all i don't know do you play
guitar with all the episodes no just
some of them
that's funny
here just
you want to look for it on youtube
oh all right that's my instagram just
type it in
yeah
yeah
what's your handle
now you have
what is your handle oh it's hannah
banan's
bonanza that's a good one
bananza it's my gamertag too
find me on steam
yeah i mean i appreciate your
competitiveness and your uh
you know your morality no i don't
appreciate any of that about you
i love you too hannah bonanza
just like this right here
but yeah i mean at least there's a code
to it and you don't go into beast mode
until you have to but it turns out you
have to a lot because we're living with
crazy people although savages are in
these streets well also i feel like when
it comes to certain things like
basketball people are always trying to
come at me
because yeah because you look a certain
way yeah because i look like i could
play basketball honey but yeah
you're an athletic black man people
assume i could play basketball from the
moment i stepped on the last talker too
and that pisses people off
i can handle anything but all that fast
talking that's where i draw my line see
yeah
it's just
when it comes to basketball specifically
i get like a benefit of the doubt that
like automatically just off the jump
people start people naturally assume i'm
good even if i was [ __ ] at night and you
play basketball and you're good at it
but even when i walk on the court before
i ever touch a basketball people just
assume i'm good and i know i'm not
they're correct
they are they're proven correct which is
the problem because the next black guy
that's like no i suck at basketball
they're gonna be like what there's no
way yeah luckily that doesn't happen
that often
only in uh what's that show the office
when he grabs when he drafts carl or
whatever stanley
i don't know i don't [ __ ] it anyways
i don't watch the office that's probably
the whitest thing you've said
the only thing i know about the office
is there's an episode where they play
basketball and there's a black guy in
the office and michael's the main guy he
picks the black guy first and the black
guy's terrible at basketball and i think
to myself every day like there's gotta
be one black dude who just hates how
often he was just like nah dude i don't
play basketball everyone's just like
dude you gotta play you're just like
tall black athletic he's like nah dude i
play the trumpet like he just doesn't
give a [ __ ] and he must hate how often
that [ __ ] happens to him especially in
like high school in that situation yeah
i hate how often that happens to me it's
a five foot one
and people are constantly like hanging
out when people assume my messages you
must be so good at basketball and i'm
like i know i look like that but yeah
you guys used to be the best at
basketball apparently long lineage long
lineage yeah they were
you used to be the best at until they
left they were the only ones playing
right until they were like hey they were
because they were like the only
like
whites allowed in and then yeah and then
they let one black dude play and they're
just like
let's be agents we're gonna
we're gonna switch to being managing
yeah they got dunked on by kareem one
time they're like i mean black people
are just physically more gifted than
a lot of other races have you every
other race so have you ever heard of
jimmy the greek like or the jimmy the
greek story
probably do you know like have you heard
of that hannah
like there was a guy in like the early
like late 80s early 90s or whatever and
he was like one of those sports
personalities like way back in the day
he used to like handicap sports and talk
like sports gambling and stuff and his
name was jimmy the greek and one night
on air he was talking about the reason
why the black athlete is superior is
because when uh slaves came when they
brought over only one you had to be the
strongest and the fittest to survive the
trek from africa to the united states in
those conditions first of all and then
like second of all the way that they
treated like they the way that they had
like the breeders on there and they're
like the way they treat like property it
was like yeah but they were only
breeding like the strongest and like
they would take like the healthiest like
the best like breeders and they breathe
this and like his assertion was that
because of that that's the reason a
predominant a majority of like black
american athletes are genetically
predisposed to being more athletic is
because of those combination of those
factors meant that a majority of the
black people were like
they weren't just like not every black
person is better but just like the black
people that made it here and survived
had like stronger genetics yeah people
were just sitting in offices
i don't know black people were working
but needless to say he said this and
jimmy the greek like they were like what
they just shut him down yeah he was
canceled they they shut his ass down and
like he was like banned and like taken
off the air and they were like when was
this this was in like the early 90s late
80s oh okay okay so he got yeah he was
canceled before getting canceled was
cool but i've always found it was
interesting people's reactions to that
and what do you guys think about like
that assertion that like i don't think
it's the only reason because black
people in africa are athletic as [ __ ] i
i know i'm not saying it's already like
athletic but i'm saying like you don't
even need slavery even if you didn't
have slavery black people would be way
more athletic than the average person
i'm not a biologist i don't know if it's
all very black i'm not not
i don't do science when it comes to
genetics i read a little bit also a
school teacher so maybe she i
think we've had a lot of conversations
so let's see what we got in in the
i don't think people breed fast enough
to breed genetic traits in that way
but i mean i'm not saying
that there aren't
genetic traits
that align with like certain racial like
whatever but like i don't know that
like okay like so are we supposed to
take that assertion
and then compare that to what like
african-american lineage versus people
who came from africa and then
lineage that's i'm not talking about
that i'm talking about immediately
like the immediate birth of a child if
your parents have certain genes then
those genes are passed down to the
children so i'm not talking about like
lineage or traits right right that's why
i'm that's why i'm saying in order to
maybe
examine that further you would have to
look
out
along with the physical attributes comes
trauma and inherited trauma so how much
does that take away well i mean get
black people down i think there's a lot
of inherited trauma around i don't think
but i think regardless if your family
was born into slavery
like lineage wise how could you not have
inherited trauma regardless of the other
aspects of it like that fact itself
i think the fact that the united states
has never been able to come to terms or
like be open about its slavery past i
think has really helped or or slowed
down or impeded the process of healing
in this country and people coming
together because there's this thing
that's like the prevailing attitude i
think when it comes to like the
historical looking back on slavery's
like wasn't us dude it happened let it
go dude you move on like you know and
there's this aspect of it and i think it
makes it hard to do that which i i don't
know for better or worse it just is what
it is in this country but i think until
that gets addressed i don't think we'll
ever fully be able to move past that
because it's better for white people to
accept the uh unearned guilt than for
black people to accept the unearned
economic disadvantage well and if you're
talking about trauma like i i
you can't you can't tell me that people
like oh these traumas all this and
trauma's inheriting all this except for
when it comes to slavery like nope that
doesn't count forget about it like it's
a weird thing that it's a weird kind of
difference that people have when it
comes to those inherited experiences or
how they perceive it in my opinion
they're the ones that decide like oh now
it's all good okay it's not me like
you're you shouldn't be the one to
decide that like
obviously you want to say that yeah but
you could it's like is this like weird
thing if somebody
robs a bank
or robs a bunch of people's accounts and
then gives you the money and you get to
keep it like dude i didn't take the
money and that but it's your money
you're still benefiting from having this
money that was taken from other people
even if you didn't do it it wasn't your
choice you denying the fact that you're
benefiting from that money being given
to you at no cost of your own like look
at that they just gave it to me now i
just have it it's not my fault yeah
imagine if the nazis did that after
world war ii like that was there was
like
that's kind of like a huge difference
between like
the us and germany is like
in germany like you don't go there and
find like
old like nazi statues like nah they took
that [ __ ] down because like
your statues your monuments that
represent something about your values
like as a country and so like
it was mad
weird like touring other countries and
seeing how like
oh yeah like they just actually made a
choice about what they were gonna use to
represent them and it wasn't like yeah
i mean it takes crazy people to go from
europe where you had like bach and
mozart
and like victorian era dresses and gowns
and then to go to america and trap
beavers for a living and then own people
and live with them as slaves and just
like have plantations
and then they're like i'm badass i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm never gonna apologize
for that like that's like
like this that's the whole what that's
sort of the attitude well the thing
about it is
if you look on a deeper level a lot of
people want to be like slavery it was
just economics it was just for the money
but if you look deeper into what people
were saying and why i think that apology
or that that reaction of oh it happened
and it's bad like we're sorry for it is
never going to happen especially in the
states is because slavery wasn't just
economic slavery was a deep-seated
belief
that they because of the the factor of
being white
were better and therefore deserved to
essentially make these lesser people
work for them because they were better
for them that was like an inbuilt idea
in slavery if you look at the people
that wrote that that were writing in the
south and the like the people that wrote
the legislation and why they wanted to
keep slavery like it goes past just the
economic thing it was a deep-seated
belief of being better than people now
if you look at
the the progression of that because you
still have after that you have jim crow
and segregation all the way up until
very recently i mean parts of
mississippi were in other parts of the
south weren't integrating until the
1990s and even later in some places so
you still have an ingrained deep-seated
belief passed down from generations that
we are better than them and that's a
deep-seated belief that a lot of people
have and not just in this toxic yeah it
poisons you for other people not just
black people like i'm better than this
white person i'm better than this woman
i'm better than a lot of people but i
think it shows itself most prevalent in
that because of the visual
representation and how easy it is to see
the difference
and so that's the deep-seated thing i
think a lot of liberals always act like
oh if we just show these people like the
smart ideas because they're not as smart
as us they don't if we show them the
facts and the figures then they'll see
things our way and it's not true because
it doesn't have anything to do with
being smart or knowledge if you don't
know and you're trying to convince me
that the people back then didn't know
slavery was wrong you're lying to
yourself because even then they knew it
was wrong george washington talked about
it and the scourge of slavery they wrote
about it they all knew what they were
doing so to say like oh we can't judge
it on that time if you judge it just on
the basis of morality they morally knew
that it was a bad thing to do so that
deep seat of belief in those things
they're not accidents and that's why
they get perpetuated because it was an
accident it was very purposeful and it
was a deep part of that culture for a
lot of people yeah they thought they
deserved to live like that like a
plantation owner and owning a bunch of
people and like this is our land we get
to do what we want and it's like that's
worked its way into american culture
absolutely and you look at further past
slavery you look at the native americans
manifest destiny it is our destiny to
convey these natives these savages we
must convert them like that
yeah we must we must move them off it's
better for them we know better than
these people what's best for them it was
a deep-seated that's what happens when
you you believe you're better so do you
think america can be recovered or do you
think that's too deeply ingrained in our
mythology and we just need to come up
with a completely new one it depends how
deep they're going they're willing to go
to unseat that like how much are you
willing to admit how much are you
willing to go to make amends for that
and i don't think america would ever do
that because that would be admitting to
the wrongness of what would happen
instead of writing it off as a that was
the time
but i do think too like so much of it is
like
in a sense like a behavior right and
like
what we see with societies is like
we really tend to see like more of that
like hyper nationalism hyper like
fixation on race like when
economic conditions are really poor and
that's like a historical
cyclical thing that we see
and so like i think they're really
yeah that's funny
no someone just some people are funny
someone made the point that slave owners
got reparations which is so true
yeah the reconstruction yeah i'm just
saying like at a certain point like all
of this stuff necessitates like othering
people and seeing them as less than
people
and so those are also behaviors as a
society that we can catch and we can
call each other on right like the south
so much of like our political polar
polarization like everything we do
hinges on this type of like dehumanizing
aspect like
i don't know coven definitely made it
hard but like actually spending time
together
talking to people like here's here's a
question kind of that [ __ ] makes a
difference
so kind of play devil's advocate here
because
so i've i thought about this
to kind of see maybe i'm crazy but still
doesn't have enough tell me what you
guys think about this right so there's
this idea that like everyone's like okay
like do the right thing but like i feel
like the united states or in general our
society is so adversarial and i feel
like you think that's a product of our
society or just human nature in general
that we need like
we need like a foil we need someone that
or like an idea or something that we
fight so like you look back historically
versus whether it's the nazis or vietnam
and the comedies like we've always had
like they or someone that we're against
the taliban or whatever we always as a
society have to be having like a foe
that we can go against so do you think
that's like a requirement because we've
kind of built that and what do you think
the alternative to that would be i think
it's like they have that the the most
basic thing you can do as a country is
like them versus us and it's like we're
falling for that trap it's like a child
and i think we can develop culturally
and societally to like
have higher ideals and be like i know
this is boring but working together and
giving everyone health care is going to
make everything better so it's like i
think we just need to develop past like
our bloodlust and our most primal
pleasure centers being stimulated
i mean that's asking the average person
to be above there but we already are all
the time do you or do you think we're
that far past it though i mean look at
where we do it
when we're like going to cubicles and
offices we're suppressing our primal
desires but we're just doing in a
useless direction so if we can just
reorganize like what we feel primarily
about and what we feel like disciplined
and human about and i think it's very
possible but we just don't try it all
but i think going to the cubicle is our
primal desire right we're that's our
shelter that's our food is going to that
cubicle because it does that so that is
the primary right but it's like divorce
from reality where it's like or nature
where like it doesn't necessarily
look like food like it's not like
hunting a buffalo but we tell ourselves
this will get us food in the future and
if we're just like i know that it feels
good to kill the jews right now but that
won't get us food in the future i think
we can make that connection just like we
made it with the cubicle
but we don't instead we're like the the
jew or the mexicans are taking food away
from our table or whatever but that's
the thing and and
but even before you look at like
societies right like you look at like
african cultures right so being born in
africa there's like a lot of tribes and
these tribes used to war with each other
a lot and you look at like native
american tribes in america and they used
to war with each other and it's like
and that's before societies were ever
like built in that sense you always have
this like what is ours it's almost like
an innate human nature is that like
you're protecting what is yours in terms
of that like right past that so do you
think that's more on the core of like
who hume what humans are as a as like an
evolved species past that because that's
what that step above is that makes us be
able to create everything from we have
to this technology and be able to
manipulate
the land around us yeah on the flip side
the negative side of that is then
because we create these things that have
different values and they were
amazing and grandiose and all that we
then have to protect what's ours that's
what comes with creating more than that
so do you think
that that that's the the negative side
of the coin that comes with being a step
above an animal in terms of where they
just kind of live off instinct and they
don't have that quality yeah like that
you think that's like the flip side of
that coin like it comes with it
yeah i mean if you can choose what to
feel like an animal about then like we
we already transcend our animal nature
in so many ways i think like this is
just a pretty easy i mean if we can do
it individually we can do it as a group
oh that's a whole different argument the
the hive mind and the collective thought
process because the individual and the
mob are two different things it's like
so funny when you look at economics and
how like
microeconomics it's all just like okay
yeah those are like logical principles
that make sense and then you
put it on an aggregate level and you get
macro
and it
all of the logic just like flips it's
just
people in in groups functions so [ __ ]
differently
and beautifully also a time jack
already yeah it's 6 33 gotta catch that
plane yeah gotta catch that flight well
[ __ ] man that's a good time thanks for
coming thanks for having us
thanks for uh attempting to help me
settle
hans you gotta get revenge for me i know
well thank you guys good night